ce pourrait être une terrible erreur qui
commit la justice française celle de
libérer un délinquant sexuel beaucoup
trop tôt où est la faille dans cette
histoire en effet alors que cet
agresseur été condamné à cinq ans de
prison dont un avec sursis en décembre
2018 pour séquestration agression
sexuelle et violences sur son
ex-compagne
il aurait bénéficié d'une libération
anticipée en mai 2020 alors qu'il lui
restait encore un an et demi à purger il
fallait faire de la place dans la prison
pour éviter des risques trop élevés de
contamination à sa sortie l'homme a
pourtant récidivé en violant une jeune
fille de 17 ans alors qu'il devait être
derrière les barreaux à ce moment là
dans une expertise psychiatrique et dans
un rapport pénitentiaire il était
indiqué que cet individu était dangereux
et qu'il présentait un risque de
récidive élevé quelque chose d'un
soutenable pour le père de la mineure
d'autant plus que l'agresseur aurait
bénéficié d'une libération anticipée
covit 19 pour désengorger les prisons où
la propagation était trop forte
mercredi le père de la jeune fille a
porté plainte contre l'état pour faute
lourde
il est avec nous ce soir avec son avocat
pour lancer un cri du coeur merci d'être
avec nous patrice merci d'être là
vraiment merci maître fabien rajon
d'être avec nous vous êtes avocat de la
victime
on a tous entendu ce récit c'est
incroyable tout a commencé au printemps
2020 l'agresseur dany j'étais à la
prison de lyon corbas où le taux
d'occupation était de 130 % pour limiter
la propagation du virus en prison un
juge horreur des ordonné sa libération
le 4 mai 2000 vingt six mois après cet
homme qui aurait dû être derrière les
barreaux va violer anne-lise 17 ans
patrice qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comment quand vous apprenez la chose
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au japon la
chose en brandon la gendarmerie donc on
annonçant que ma fille s'était fait
violer qui ont vous appeler chez vous at
il faut vous rendre à la gendarmerie
on nous a appelés oui il fallait se
rendre à la jambe à la gendarmerie donc
le lendemain en fait du viol donc
c'était déjà un choc savoir que ma
propre fille a été violée
donc je me suis rendu à la gendarmerie
avec avec mon épouse et une gendarme
comment vous annonce ça vous dit
il y analyse est là quand vous
l'annonçons nan nan en fait analysé t
che était chez un ami protéger d'accord
on sécurité d'accor donc la gendarmerie
voulions vous vaut parler de provo roues
voilà vous êtes vous êtes convoqué en
fait sans vous annonce que votre fille a
été violée par un individu donc on se
pencheront la gendarmerie avec mon
épouse est donc on s'installe et la
gendarme la gendarme nous dit notre bout
de fille a été violée et c'est une
libération qu'ovide 19 donc déjà il
fallait encaissé le le fait que ma fille
bien chauffés violée le deuxième choc la
double peine
ça a été de savoir que cette personne a
été libéré sous caution
19 c'est à dire par rapport à la crise
sanitaire kobe de 19
c'est dans cet homme il avait été
condamné à quatre ans de prison pour des
faits notamment de nature sexuelle vingt
quatre en quatre ans forcément vous
apprenez donc que votre fille s'est fait
violer en plus que son agresseur aurait
dû être en prison
c'est ce qui vous met le plus haut voilà
c'est ça ça vous met dans un état
j'imaginais leurs épouses ccc ccc au
delà de la colère ce faire il sait ça a
été une explosion interne en fait de
tout notre corps à nous on s'est dit on
on a on a on a touché
on a touché notre propre chair on nous a
atteint on a sali ma fille on a pénétré
ma fille jade clair net précis par un
individu qui n'aurait jamais dû sortir
prison il a violenté son ex-campagne
compagne pardon mais sans majorité donc
un criminel je comprends pas m
fabien allons ils n'ont pas vérifié les
risques de récidive
dans des cas comme ça comme un espace il
ya 130 % d'occupation dans une prison
comment ça se passe pour libérer que
telle ou telle personne on va on va se
poser est effectivement une question une
question qu'on se pose tous comment cet
individu qui porte lui mentions sur son
casier judiciaire qui a été condamnée
donc à cinq ans d'emprisonnement
un an avec sursis quatre en quatre ans
ferme pour avoir séquestré séquestration
détention arbitraire c'est la première
la première infraction tenté de violer
sa a été requalifiée en agression en
agression sexuelle donc la qualification
qui a été retenu séquestrations
détention arbitraire agression sexuelle
sur son conjoint et troisième infraction
violence avec effectivement patrice l'a
dit 120 jours d'itt et et brimont cet
individu il va être libéré après deux
ans de détention sans audience ni débat
au motif effectivement des collines
c'est une autre question principale dans
le cadre de cette dans le cadre de cette
affaire
alors vous décidez vous avez décidé
d'intenter en route ou un recours contre
l'état pour faute grave
qu'est ce qu'ils auraient dû faire
l'état m contre laval à face à la
surpopulation
ce que je sais que s'il ya à peu près
6000 détenus qui ont été libérés à cause
de ces deux crises sanitaires absolument
absolument effectivement il ya eu des
libérations massives dans certains cas
notamment au visa du régime des
réductions de peines supplémentaires et
un dispositif de réduction de peine
supplémentaire exceptionnelle qui a été
mis en place
la vraie question qu'on se pose c'est
effectivement dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la propagation compte le coz ide
en établissement carcéral
il fallait prendre des mesures il
fallait effectivement peut-être baisser
cette jauge c'est pas notre notre sujet
qui nous préoccupe mais baisser la jauge
pour qui est né criminel section on peut
faire preuve de discernement il ya
peut-être effectivement des personnes
qui sont incarcérés qui était en fin de
peine ou qui avait des petites peines
qui avaient été condamnés à des petites
peines qui a été incarcéré pour des
motifs moins graves
moi ce qui me choque ce qui choque mon
client avec ce qu'ils imaginent le choc
l'été les émissions c'est qu'on est en
matière d'infractions sexuelles on est
en
matière de violence conjugale mais 120
jours d'itt et élite était ce une notion
médico légal qui peut paraître un petit
peu un petit peu technique mais je pense
que ça parle aux gens 120 jours à malte
est la première victime
elle a été supplicié par cet individu
donc effectivement ces libérations
qu'ovide vous pouvez effectivement les
envisager pour des détenus qui avaient
décalé à purger des peines pour lequel
le trouble à l'ordre public était
largement inférieure mais pas passa pas
ce type dans la grèce seraient pas des
infractions sexuelles
l'agresseur a été vite appréhendé après
le absolument il y lit en examen et il
est il est actuellement en détention
provisoire il a été appréhendé le 5
novembre
on était quand même sous pression aussi
ça ne l'a su assez ça parce que ça ça va
on savait pas où était cet individu donc
on a eu peur quand même des représailles
assure c'est normal c'était les nuées
ont été très courte
les journées ont été longues et un
mot-valise elle se reconstruit tout
doucement à se reconstruit tout
doucement elle est forte elle est là
elle a conscience de la gravité en fait
à la conscience de la gravité
lll et or elle est torturée mais elle
veut combattre elle veut pas laisser
passer ça sous silence
vous avez ma fille ma fille ne ne
laissera pas passer ça sous silence
mon épouse et moi même on peut pas se
taire c'est pas possible c'est ça suffit
c'est de cesser de violence sur sur ce
fait fait faites aux femmes c'est
inconcevable inconcevable la personne
faisait 1 mètre 90 120 kg qu'est ce que
pouvait faire ma fille non mais est ce
que pouvait faire pas rien moi je vous
dis je je comprends ce soir et je pense
que les téléspectateurs comprennent
votre colère c'est et on a vu la
réaction du ministre de la justice à
eric dupond moretti qui a évoqué ce
dossier il ya dit qu'il n'y a pas eu de
faille et et que éviter toute la
récidive est impossible mais c'est vrai
que moi je me mets à votre place et
séries qu on est tous à terry pas ce qui
s'est passé surtout sur une libération
qu'ovide et quand vous nous raconter le
truc les les gens je le vois sur les
réseaux sociaux hallucine sais c'est
incroyable gilles verdez c'est
incroyable et quand on voit le dossier
c'est fou par
il y avait risque de récidive c'est
effectivement une précédente agression
sexuelle et quand on lit ce que dit
l'administration dans l'impression que
tous les services se renvoient la balle
le juge d'application des peines le
parquet l'administration pénitentiaire
le ministre défend les services
mais quand même je suis d'accord avec
vous vous attaquez l'état parce qu'on a
l'impression que l'état a remis un
prédateur en liberté ce dossier est
incroyable c'est pour ça que vous
attaquez je pense l'état il ya
effectivement dans cette dans cette
décision 2.2.1 portant sur la
dangerosité de l'individu
il ya un premier point sur le risque de
récidive le risque de récidive il a été
évoqué par le spip
le spip qu'est ce que c'est cette
service minutes ans hier d'insertion et
de probation qui évoque je cite le site
le spip un risque de récidive
qualifiée de faible à moyen le premier
point est deuxième point à l'expertisé
psychiatrique de cet individu qui a aidé
vues et analysées par un expert
psychiatre qui évoque effectivement un
risque de récidive qui ne peut être
éliminée premier point on peut dire que
c'est une une prudence de sa part mais
qui évoquent et c'est beaucoup plus
inquiétant et c'est bien c'est bien ce
qui s'est passé des tendances au passage
à l'acte et héros agressif alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
là aussi c'est des termes médicaux
légaux tendance au passage à l'acte et
héros hétéro agressive donc simplement
effectivement c'est un risque de viols
ou d'agressions ces créatures j'ai
indiqué noir sur blanc dans cette
décision
patrice aujourd'hui forcément votre vie
à a été complètement bouleversée par ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui votre combat
c'est c'est quoi c'est aujourd'hui c'est
c'est juste que ça voilà que ça se
reproduise plus pour peut-être que ça se
reproduise plus et puis que que les
langues se délient aussi que certaines
femmes certaines zones soient kiki qui
ont subi un viol dénonce aussi vous en
voulez à la justice française à la
justice pour moi pour l'instant c'est du
silence je n'entends rien c'est du
silence gens veulent juste ici bien sûr
où j'en veux on épouse ma famille mes
soutiens mes amis j'en veux j'en veux la
justice
je ne comprends pas qu'un individu soit
libéré jeu
je sais j'ai l'impression que c'est
irréel
moi ce que je ressens dans votre
témoignage et chier parce que c'est ce
que ressentent les téléspectateurs c'est
qu'on a en face de personnes qui disent
nous on a fait ce qu'il fallait faire
regarder on nous a demandé de libérer
six mille six cents personnes
donc voilà ça se passe comme ça on a
suivi le protocole et là on en face d'un
papa qui sait que sa fille a vécu un
drame qui va la suivre toute sa vie et
on a l'impression d'un côté on a des
bureaucrates et de l'autre on a des
humains on a des gens voilà d'aider des
idées et ça c'est ce qui ressort encore
de de votre témoignage ce soir et ça je
trouve que moi là je la justice un
moment ça se passe comme si c'est assez
il faut il faut il faut il faut essayer
de travailler peut-être que je dis une
connerie avec le coeur aussi avec le
avec l'émotion avec et je pas ce que
vous en pensez m mais je trouve que
c'est c'est assez curieux aujourd'hui la
différence de perception qu'on a quand
on entend un patrice et quand on entend
les réponses de de la justice mouais je
crois surtout que c'était notre
responsabilité ma responsabilité
d'avocats la responsabilité de de
patrice de son de son épouse de révéler
cette situation parce que si on prend
pas l'initiative nous de parler nous
effectivement d'organiser une conférence
de presse comme la conférence de presse
que nous avons organisée avant-hier à à
lyon est-ce que vous relaie d'opinion
médias vous auriez pu diffuser ces
informations c'est vous faire les
témoins de la souffrance de patrice de
la souffrance d'anne lise et des proches
de cette de cette jeune fille nous avons
donc pris cette initiative effectivement
pour pour évoquer ces faits pour briser
le silence parce que rien pour patrice
pour sa famille ne serait pire que de ce
que de se taire dans cette affaire merci
en tout cas patrice qu'est ce que je
voulais c'est le mot de la fin
qu'est-ce que vous pourrez dire ce soir
ben j'aimerais que justice soit rendue
et que la justice soit impartial et en
fait j'ai ma vie pour l'instant c'est
elle est détruite
j'ai on va avoir du mal à se
reconstruire avec avec ma famille
mes deux filles ça va être compliqué et
j'aimerais que j'aimerais qu'on soit
entendu qu'on soit écoutée et qu'on ait
des réponses claires précises et c'est
ce que j'attends c'est ce que j'attends
je vous comprends tout à fait patrice et
votre témoignage était très très fort ce
soir merci patrice d'être venu merci
maître fabien rajon d'avoir été avec
nous également
j'espère que ça va avancer